so basically we're gonna it's like shark
tank but the viewers can invest and i
think all right so we're gonna have six
startups each startup gets two minutes
to pitch and then we have up to five
minutes to ask questions and last time i
don't know if you remember the sean but
last time
we the companies that pitched ended up
raising like millions and millions of
dollars
[Music]
all right what up sean do you play video
games
of course i play video games do you
really not as much
i don't really play at all but um
i mean i just i don't i'm not like a
gamer but do you know what xbox cloud is
i didn't know what that was
uh yeah kind of i'm in the ps i'm in the
playstation universe i don't really use
xbox cloud but it's like the cloud
gaming thing for them
yeah
but basically i i paid like a dollar to
play
flight sim do you know what flight sim
is yeah of course you probably love that
thing it's awesome i just started doing
it and like because me and sarah are
thinking about going to korea and i'm
like let's just go like fly to seoul
right now and see what it's like like
you can fly around and i paid a dollar
for it and i played it on my computer
it's so cool i've never like been a
video gamer but it's awesome
a video gamer
just gamer
hello fellow millennials yeah
uh wait so do we not see these pitches
what's going on here so um i see a bunch
of comments i've got a screen over here
do you have the the comments set up
oh okay here we go
and then um
i believe
courtney or someone else is going to
control it so someone's going to come up
and they're going to pitch for two
minutes
okay great and are we we're really
investing money this time
maybe i'm not doing it if it's i'm only
doing if it's good well yeah only if
it's good of course i'm not uh not gonna
just throw money at something bad but
i'm ready i got the checkbook out so i'm
ready today i think fifty hundred
thousand dollars would be awesome to
deploy if there's a great startup in
here but we shall see what's up i can
see the chat
so let's give a background here all
right so this thing it's called
stocks.com
it's like a live shark tank type of uh
company i'm an investor in it so i have
like a i have some interest here but um
you're not an investor right sean of
this company no i'm just working for
free right now yes i don't care if
people use it or not but i just i just
wanted to disclose that but
so six companies describe the describe
the format it's cool there's basically a
video screen where they pitch the
investors there's right now 250 people
watching live
and then there's a live chat so people
in the audience and they could tag
themselves as angel investor founder vc
just i don't know normal you know muggle
and you they can chat during the pitches
they can also express interest to invest
uh which will let them like connect with
that founder after the fact so it's kind
of like a way it's a way to do angel
investing no matter where you are in the
world
making shark tank you know the default
process for investing which is pretty
dope and uh yeah as calvin says no small
bush stuff today that's my only rule
with these founders coming pitching
coming and pitching they always say
what's your advice i say it's the same
as always no small boy stuff all right
so so basically we're gonna it's like
shark tank but the viewers can invest
and i think all right so we're gonna
have six startups each startup gets two
minutes to pitch and then we have up to
five minutes to ask questions and last
time i don't know if you remember the
sean but last time
we the companies that pitched ended up
raising like millions and millions of
dollars so it was it was pretty
interesting so let's see if we get that
uh
life change just another day just
another life change as far as getting
concerned well because we so basically
we're doing this live and then we're
gonna air on our youtube and podcast and
i think people can still invest at that
point but so yeah a lot of lives were
changed but let's check it out so let's
we're gonna go uh the first one uh jesse
you're gonna uh bring it up there you go
two minutes and then
uh we do five minute q a
awesome hey guys luke from cherry here
hey sam hey sean um so cherry is a uh
exists to ensure accommodation
businesses get more direct bookings and
in turn giving consumers better travel
deals
so online travel agencies today like
expedia booking.com and airbnb bringing
around 250 billion dollars in bookings
resulting around 35 billion in
commission fees
a average property can sometimes pay up
to 30 commissions on those bookings
with the market power that these guys
have it's really hard for an individual
property to get direct bookings and
that's where we've come in
meet cherry cherry is a free browser
extension it gives you deals when
searching for accommodations you can
find it right now at joincherry.com
so imagine that you're searching for a
property you're looking on booking.com
you found one you liked and bam cherry's
going to pop up it's going to show you a
better deal for booking directly with
the property
and on clicking get deal will take you
directly through to the properties
direct website we copy across the guests
the check in the checkout and the promo
code allowing you to check out with
these
now sam imagine we did this with
marathon ranch on airbnb you could have
cherry popping up showing a deal
directly to customers
allowing them to come through the direct
guest booking engine on your own website
all of our properties have a dedicated
back end allowing them to manage their
deal daily monthly or seasonally they've
got full control
the current product works across desktop
and in the future months we'll be
launching all your favorite travel deals
directly from your pocket on
mobile we're highly adaptable we work
across all accommodation providers like
city hotels resorts vacation rentals and
the future proofing of our product is
across attractions flights and also car
hire
within four short months we're
approaching a thousand partner
properties in australia new zealand and
canada from all the major brands you
might be aware of and by november we'll
be launching to the us with an expected
20 000 partner properties
we're the team to get this done we've
got a mixture of great travel and tech
experience and a graded sounding
advisory board across marketplaces
travel and tech as well so what do you
say should we get back to traveling
oh
nice little closing do you work on that
today
yeah i did that's good
that's good i like that
this is really like shark tank
so what do you say
shall we fly through the sky
all right so
okay so let's start off uh sam give me
your initial initial thoughts
i don't know this space that much so my
initial thoughts are i'm trying to
figure out how this is different from
just like expedia with a chrome plug-in
or is that it is that like the
dumbed-down version
yeah we're essentially allowing uh
properties to get more direct bookings
by having it pop up on online travel
agencies sending them direct to the
property's website so they're not having
to pay the large commission fees and
there's only two-way incentives so the
buyer gets a little discount and then
the hotel
doesn't have to pay the referral fee to
expedia right correct instead they pay a
referral to you presumably
yeah we charge on a performance base and
sometimes on a subscription base
so are you cheaper than expedia then
yeah correct so for us we charge a
performance fee of uh 10 a month and
then we pay 79 cents a click whereas
some of these properties are paying you
know upwards of 30 commission on some of
these bookings and the way it works is
you have this
uh chrome plugin installed i go to
hiltoncydney.com or whatever it is and
it says hey
sorry i go to expedia i go to some other
website where there's hotels listed it
goes hey by the way if you just click
this little uh it's like honey so i just
like see like a little notification on
my chrome thing it says if you click
that you're actually going to save ten
dollars if you just come straight to our
website is that right correct so
how do you get the the chrome extension
users right that seems like the the hard
part so how do you get them today so as
you said you had 3 000 of them so where
did those 3 000 come from and where did
the next
10 or 30 000 come from and how much does
that cost you
yeah so
what we've done is we've been able to
partner with the hotels that we're
signing up
which has made it really easy for from a
customer acquisition point of view so
for instance we're launching with around
300 new properties in canada at the
moment and they're actually rolling it
out to their loyalty base of around 2
million members
from an email point of view and so we'll
partner with them and that's the
engaging point of view that we're we're
going out with um and then we've got
some paid media rolling out across
youtube and reddit and those are the
likes
sorry so i don't understand so why does
the hotel care to tell its customers to
install cherry
yeah so so they're they're almost sick
of paying these large commission fees
that they do to the online travel
agencies so for them to be able to bring
their members
incentivize them to use the cherry
product while they're searching across
all of the different online travel
agencies it's a benefit for them to then
not have to pay those commissions every
single time
do you think that what
let's say that you're you're you're
actually advising people not to invest
in you because the travel industry is so
hard like what's like the honest truth
that you would say because the travel
industry like performance marketing in
the travel industry seems like the most
cutthroat thing there is next to like
you know ranking for like lawyer terms
like mesothelioma lawsuit you know what
i mean like what else
definitely um well i guess the data that
we've seen travel over the last four
months is that it's actually back and
it's bigger than 2019 pre-pandemic
levels that we saw
and not just that it's it's back from a
volume perspective but in terms of what
people it's spending is higher so the
average room rate of dollar value that
people are spending is is going higher
so yeah i'm trying to tell you not to
invest at this point but um from from
our regard travels back and bigger than
ever
so um it seemed like honey did a great
job because they they found a way to
acquire users for cheap and i think
youtubers and influencers were like one
of the big strategies it seems like you
could do that with these like travel
bloggers travel tips you know flight
deals hotel deal type of uh
type of bloggers youtubers that sort of
thing
have you guys started doing that and
what do you see what's the what is the
what does it cost you to get an install
when you pay right because i don't know
i'm not really buying this uh
this idea that hotels are just gonna
keep spamming their their customers to
install your app that just see just
because they're so fed up with expedia i
don't know i don't really buy that yeah
yeah so when we first started um we were
noticing 10 12 of uh of a cpa on on
facebook and instagram and we realized
that that was just not continually
achievable and so we switched and we
pivoted very much into the reddits and
the pinterest of the world and we were
able to get down to sort of that two
three dollar mark um but youtube is
where we identified the big growth how
much did you spend
we were spending a few thousand dollars
a month
um
yeah and then what and what what's
what's the customer worth so what do
those customers generate for you uh you
know in a year yeah so the customers
aren't necessarily the generators for us
it's the the properties paying the
performance and the subscription fee but
the average saving for a customer could
be up to you know 150 dollars a year in
uh in travel savings
gotcha okay they're telling us we're at
time uh luke thank you
thanks guys yeah me and sam will quickly
debrief and then we'll move on to the
next pitch
i'm out i'm out not it has nothing to do
with him it's just the industry i'm just
i i it's not you it's not me
yeah
yeah so look i'm one of the very few so
i uh there's this weird rule i don't
know if it's a law or it's a rule but
basically have you ever heard about this
where um like expedia or some other
company they there's this regulation
that they have to display in like the
same rate across all websites if that
rate is going to be publicly available
have you ever heard of that no but that
makes sense so there's these guys i met
who bought these um
instagram handles like at hotel and now
they have like 50 million followers
across all their things and it says dm
us for a good hotel deal and you dm them
and they have a chat bot that figures
out where you want to go and then they
can actually spend send you way more
exclusive deals because they don't have
to follow the law because it's not it's
a private conversation and i think
that's like an interesting take this
that's a that's a really intriguing take
to me this take that this guy has uh
luke i think it's also interesting i
don't think it's good enough though to
like be
crazy different from all the other folks
out there in an industry that's to me as
somewhat uneducated seems like it's
really really really really tough to
succeed in i think the hard part here is
i'm not installing this unless i'm
traveling
right like i'm not just oh let me just
uh preemptively install this so i think
travel is so infrequent it's hard to get
people to install this and i didn't love
that answer you gave at the end he's
like oh our customers don't generate
money for us well they do right they're
the ones who go book and so you know on
average of the people that install 25
actually go book something and of those
25 who book on average that generates 20
for us and so i can tell you no public
math but let me just do it anyways
that's you know whatever four or five
bucks that that customer's worth for me
and i i bought them for two so that's
your spread there's gonna be some math
like that so that's what i'm always
looking for with founders is
can you from a bottoms-up way explain
how the money machine of your business
works i put a dollar in here then it
generates you know three dollars on the
way out um and i've done that at this
scale and now the only question is if i
scale up will that money stay the same
right that's that's what i'm looking to
do so yeah i'm out as well i like the
guy like the name but i think that honey
for travel
if it was gonna be a thing honey would
do it and if it um
you know and i also think that the and i
think the reason they don't is because
as a standalone thing it's hard to
acquire users for this because travel is
infrequent and expensive there's a
commenter in the chat room that says my
wife says she's out i agree with i agree
with ben simpson's wife and in fact i
want to know what all of your wives feel
and if your wife's not around because
she's not watching this at a 10 a.m on a
tuesday
um you know your wife and you know your
husband so just tell us in the chat
after every single pitch is your wife or
husband in or out based on what you know
about him
all right next up yeah i want to know
too and also ask them my wife is
definitely out my wife is sarah out for
you
yeah she's not in and if you want to ask
them what the what your wife's opinion
is on sean and me as well as the
startups we're okay we'll listen to that
but only if it's a good thing next up
hold on look at this cover from ollie i
keep my wife my wife away from the show
because you guys are too handsome look
i if i had a nickel for every time i
heard that you got like 15 cents
i'd have three nickels
yeah maybe 25 cents maybe we have a
whole quarter
all right uh hill pill up is the next
startup what a name
yeah hi guys pillow i am phillip
yo
that's why i took the name fill up
cheers
okay hi guys i'm ankur co-founder of
pillop and i'm here to make you millions
let's get started
so 56 percent of patients in india have
poor medication adherence and guess how
many are chronic patients in india
for 30 million so that's a big problem
and a huge opportunity for us but what
are the reasons behind this poor
adherence number one forgetfulness
people tend to forget to eat their
medication due to old age or they're
just busy with the schedule
second one is poor medication management
people take the wrong medicines at the
wrong time double those it happens more
often than you think
financial constraints
the fourth one is personal beliefs you
know some people in india believe if
they start to take medicines they have
to take it for the lifetime and the
fifth one is
unable to read doctor prescription
presenting you the pull-up solution
we pre-sort your medication by time and
date personalized as per your
prescription
but you will still forget to take
medicines due to some reason right don't
worry we got you covered
we provide medication reminders on your
preferred platform so you don't forget
to take medicine but in case you still
do your wife will remind you because
we're gonna alert her after one hour of
your medication time
and lastly we convert this beautiful
doodle art of the doctor into a pillow
planner which is much easier to
understand
we provide a one-stop solution to
improve your medication endurance
through the app through pre-sorting
pouches and our dispenser
we are a team of engineer analyst and
doctor i am a serial entrepreneur and a
yc alumni dr manish has 19 years of
experience he is a cardiologist and are
conscious of brains behind this whole
business
to put things into perspective
even if you miss one day of medication
in tuberculosis
you start again from day zero
let this sink in thank you
good job thank you
encore that was that was awesome uh let
that sink in thank you
you started and ended
with some major
restaurant owner energy right there like
you came in and said i'm here to make
you millions and you left with let that
sink in thank you i've never i've
actually never seen that and uh
i don't know i'm still a little shook
sam you take it away that was great uh
yeah i think you did a good job are you
is this an indian company is this
in india
yes
and you're like in down you're in
downtown india right now i could hear
the i could hear the uh where are you at
i'm in the capital new delhi
nice you uh you're wearing a y
combinator shirt make something people
want is this a yc company
no my previous startup was a yc company
and what was that
yeah
so this was in a winter 21 so
me and my partner we pivoted and had a
different vision for where to take the
company so i started a new is this
company basically pill pack for india
yeah kind of but
the customer insights are a bit
different so pillpack was focused on
medication management pre-sorting so
that people can stay back at home and
spend more time with the family while
our focus is on to increase the
medication a difference issue which is
reminding people
to take their medication timely
intervention
and
to make their life more easier and
convenient so i would say 50 to 60 pill
back but there's more to it and why
doesn't pillpack focus on that so is it
that in india the problem is different
like the people's behavior is different
or
why why wouldn't you just do pillpack
for india pilpak's been quite successful
is india itself not enough of a
differentiator from there no so pilpak
hasn't entered india because there has
been a recent healthcare regulation
change
so that makes it possible for india the
uh change similar to the upi if you're
aware about the payments change that
happened and change the whole fintech
industry similarly the uhi
change is happening in india moreover
due to kovite
the
e-pharmacy have been booming in the last
three years with the cheer of 45 percent
and with the online payments it has made
possible to get this technology out
there
earlier in india you know online
ordering of medicine wasn't a concept
you should change your shirt instead of
uh make something people want you should
say say uh uh make drugs people take and
uh that'll be it'll be a head turner
what is the um what's the traction like
i i feel like you gave us the high level
problem and solution pretty well
but you didn't say much about traction
so we launched two months ago last month
our traction was 1300
we on an average get an order value of
200 from our customers
per month and we have a high very high
retention rate but the as the sample
size is very small
uh
you know it doesn't make sense to say it
is 90
sure and how are you going to get
customers
so we have three channels one is b2b so
today also we made a b2b partnership
with old age homes with whom they are 20
to 30 clients staying in their old age
homes
second one is we are pushing out the
product by introducing it to the doctors
through our sales channel and third we
will be starting our influencer programs
next month once uh what's up bought and
all the technical side is you know on
track and really important question is
that zero to one on your bookshelf
yes
um i'm in
yeah is that settlers of catan
what are you what have you been saying
to um
american investors who say uh
dude american health care is too
complicated i don't know anything about
that let alone another country that you
know i may maybe don't even know that
much about
so i haven't reached out to the american
uh you know investors yet so this is my
first page i just wanted you guys to be
my you know
my investors because i love my first
million and
i've already received funding so that
you know i can get into y combinator
again and you know i have a clear part
for the next two years the funding is
secured
and for the american investor as i said
you know i haven't reached out to them
yet
and um
you said that the e-pharmacies have been
booming and that's i think that's just
very true i i looked at investing in a
um an indian you know
you know e-pharmacy
why don't they just do this um you know
as part of your offering where they
they're able to sort of um so their
focus is very different so e-pharmacies
right now have been working on two
things out of the 15 problems we have
identified they're working on the
delivery part they want to do the
delivery within three hours there are
three unicorns already in this space and
the whole market right now is discounted
no one is working on what happens post
delivery of medicines so that's the
space we want to work in and that's
where we are finding a lot of interest
from the people and
all our sales are mostly through word of
mouth so we are in the pre-launch phase
we just shared the product with 10
people and then you know we
they just shared further and now we have
250 people and next month we are doing a
proper launch
and uh and you said you're raising two
hundred thousand dollars at a four
million dollar cap is that right yeah
okay okay great and we're telling you
100 100 000.
awesome uh we're at time we can uh we
can close it up thank you so much ankur
thanks for coming on thank you sean
thank you sam thanks
um what do you think
i like it uh i'm in i would invest in
this at precede now the the the
questions i have the things i would want
to know is he mentioned that his last
company which was yc21 that's not very
long ago
it did not um not a red flag but
something to ask about
yeah yeah exactly but yeah there is some
red i see in the distance i just don't
know if it's a flag or like you know it
could be around a sign yeah
so why did his co-founder disagree what
went into that how did they handle it um
so you know that seems kind of
interesting i'd like to know a little
bit more about that
and um i'd also like to talk to some of
the e-pharmacy people and be like hey
why isn't there a pill pack for india
and just hear what they say do you have
well i guess you don't need an indian
based person to like tell you that but
do you have like a
like someone who's
somewhat of an expert on india
healthcare yeah i know a guy who runs
one of the big e pharmacies there and
then uh just in general you know this is
i'm one one dm away from getting that
answer so that would be the other
contingency for me that's why i would
pass is i don't have that i you know i i
don't i don't like you could tell he
could have told me anything about india
his healthcare and i would have said
yeah okay cool yeah so india has now
floated it's next to china you're like
oh man that's cool
[Laughter]
so like he could have said anything and
i just it's really hard for me to to
know like what the truth is right um so
i don't know if i would do it also tell
me what you think about this do you
think that it's a good pitch or not to
say we are pillpack of india we are
blank but for this country yeah
sometimes i'm like yeah okay i'm okay
with that you don't you don't have to
like you know
you don't have to sell something he
really
don't don't piss on my back and tell me
it's rain just tell me what it is yeah
exactly he should have just told us what
it is he should have said we're pulled
back for india pillpack has built a x
billion dollar business and was acquired
by amazon and they don't operate in
india because of that because of
um india specific regulations like he
said so uh the pillpack for india is
going to start in india and it's going
to be us now the things that we do that
are similar to pillpack is blank blank
that's been validated the part we're
doing that's new is this that's how i
would have pitched that business in
order to like
fast you know make it faster for the for
the investor to understand the size of
the prize do you feel partial towards
indian startups
uh more so than a non more so yeah more
so than like uh i don't like a french
startup or something
uh yeah kind of like i think i know a
little bit more about the market i've
been there i've you know family there
i've now invested in a bunch of
companies there so it all just builds
over time but also it's a humongous
market that
has just had those like uh you know what
do you call those like inflection points
or whatever basically
a billion people all got mobile phones
with internet in the last like couple
years and that just like it's a before
it's a dramatic before and after
and um so you know serving that market
building solutions for that market is
really awesome like now as a it's a
golden cohort of companies because
they're all riding the back of this
thing where one company basically gave
away 4g internet uh essentially a dirt
dirt cheap cost cheaper than in america
so a lot of people got online you know
what's up though is that big
company that was that it was a big
pakistani company that like everyone was
a fan of air or something what was it
called yeah air lift or something like
that like all you i don't know if it was
you but a bunch of my friends were like
oh this thing's this thing's awesome
this is awesome and i remember thinking
like i don't know anything about
pakistan but all my smart friends say
this is a good idea and i was like
really interested in it and i think i
ended up passing but it went out of
business and whether it's good or bad
that impacts whether i want to invest in
a foreign company because i don't like
it's like oh i don't know man i don't
know anything about this country so
i have mixed feelings right now on on
investing in locations that i know
nothing about
yeah my some of my worst investments
came from
well all these other smart people are
doing it and i don't know why they did
it i don't know if they're actually
smart i don't know if they uh you know
what their assumptions are what their
context is what they can afford to lose
and so i've made some pretty terrible
decisions like that in the past so
that's famous last words for me is like
well well the other smart people are
doing it
yeah well
sometimes that works so it worked once
for me um
all right steve campus inc
campus inc
college laundry
close close close close close i don't
know like i got like a stain on my or
like a college tattoo parlor i don't
know
love it i haven't gotten that joke
before but i appreciate it
let's go ahead all right hey everyone my
name is steven i'm the ceo of campus inc
we're a d to c and b2b merch platform
powered by college athletes and college
students we build licensed merch
platforms for universities so every
athlete in every sport has the ability
to sell merch and profit off their name
image and likeness meanwhile we train
students on those campuses in design
sales and marketing so they can support
the athletes and sell to other
organizations like the greek system last
year we did four and a half million
dollars in sales this year we're on pace
to do seven million sean you went to
duke so i'm going to pick on you a
little bit in another world you're a
five-star recruit former coach k brings
you in and introduces you to your new
nil director you have the opportunity to
sell your own branded duke merch through
campus inc we're talking jerseys custom
drops limited releases and you're gonna
earn anywhere between eight to fifteen
dollars per item sold
your jerseys are gonna be sold in the
stadium and online and when you go to
the final four you're even gonna make
money on final four apparel when you go
pro sean you're gonna be able to sell
your duke jersey for the rest of your
life
at the university of illinois we made
our college basketball team over a
hundred thousand dollars in the regular
season at
and mark cuban invested in us over a
cold email
he's helping us take this to every
college across the country so far we
have over 600 athletes in our queue
we've signed 15 schools including duke
uconn syracuse and most of the big ten
our platform solves a few significant
problems one we notice that universities
are desperate to show they're supporting
their athletes in this new nil space
coaches are losing recruits because
other schools are moving faster they
need a solution we have it and we're
there we're there for them
there's also over 180 000 d1 athletes
who are all micro influencers and don't
have the time resources or skills
to run their own merch platform
we're there to help them
finally we know that traditional d2c is
throttled and at the mercy of facebook
we'd rather reward the students we think
we have an unfair advantage in acquiring
customers when we sign schools they
connect to athletes and athletes connect
with fans and that's how we sell merch
at campus inc
all right
wow
wow no small boy stuff no small boy
stuff dude i see you put me oh wow do
you know small boys
actually i got a bone to pick with sean
sam sam sam sorry sam i designed you
guys a merch platform
here check this out oh i remember
dude nice
i remember okay
let me that is awesome and i think i
replied with send me that shirt i want
it well i said i said we could actually
the site is live right now i bought the
domain too what is it
mfmpod.shop
okay
let now let me tell you something
i wasn't trying to be an to you
i'm just an to everyone who sent
well that's why i'm helping sean out
with the duke stuff so we i get i don't
know about you sean i bet he does and
even more so i get like five or ten of
those a week of someone saying i wanted
to buy merch so we just like made a
store for you and i just i i politely
tell them to off and i think that's
what i said to you right yeah i
forwarded that to mark as well that's
why i didn't want to come on the pod no
i'm just kidding
so
now that we're friends
i'll try you nicer yeah you're crazy we
should do swag okay but um
let's get back to his business
business okay so
uh so i really like a bunch of things
about this business but i have some
questions okay so so what do i like i
like that you're basically riding the
wave of this regulatory change the nil
chains that just went into effect and
that means all the businesses that need
to serve that market of college athletes
finally being able to monetize their
name and likeness which is what nil is
about um that though all those
businesses are being created you know
last year this year and it sounds like
you're you were early on that wave
couple quick questions can you use the
team logos like you did there so
you don't need a special license for
that so that is a special license but
but we go to the university and we
basically pitch to them that we have an
inclusive and holistic solution so every
sport every athlete softball baseball
rowing right good they grant us the ip
and then we're able to build them a
whole school platform and so yeah we're
able to do what's called co-license
merchandise which is a very specific
segment of licensing and we've got those
at 15 schools you're like we've sold
tens of women's lacrosse sweatshirts
well i'll be i'll be honest our biggest
one of our biggest rev generators was
women's softball at like virginia tech
the girls just crushed it and they were
in like world series and people are
buying their stuff i mean it's not just
football and basketball amazing
what's a lear field someone was saying
how learfield owns 90 of the licensing
rights and if i know nothing about it
other than uh three seconds on wikipedia
if they own it can you also get it so
learfield it owns collegiate licensing
we get the license from them so they are
the licensed clearing house on behalf of
the university so when we go to duke for
instance we talk to duke pitch them they
say okay go apply for your license you
go log on to learfield apply duke
accepts it in the back end they're just
the exchange that you use
and is it in is learfield incentivized
to let you guys grow like uh you know at
some point do they see this as
competitive to what they do well so so
there's different parts of learfield
learfield is a licensing arm for the
university so they're there to protect
the ip of the university but when we
have something that's a really unique
segment it's hard for the university to
say no so if i just wanted to sell if
like just duke merch duke would be like
no we've got hundreds of other people
doing it but the fact that we're in a
very niche vertical the universities are
more inclined to create the best apple
opportunities for their athletes it'd be
silly for them to say no because you'd
be taking away opportunities for them
by the way we have 500 people watching
live i think your startup has 140 000 of
total interest which is pretty dope uh
people
i'm 30.
you uh you got that uh that young 22
year old dog energy
there you go
look there it is i'm a dog
thank you for proving my point all right
let's have a hot dog dude put those two
shirts in in a package and please send
them to me i'll venmo you um
those are awesome he's like dude he's
like i have a store just go buy it
give me a yeah give me that coupon
what about uh i like you're doing this
franchise model right so you're
basically going to get like kind of
passionate cheap labor on the campuses
uh and and you're going to have this set
up on each campus where they do the
design the marketing yeah and we already
have that up until nil came about that
was our thematic approach we teach
college students design and sales so
right now we have 150 students on 40
campuses they're really big into the
greek system but now that we have the
greek system and sports it makes it so
much easier for our students across the
country so okay so this is kind of a
pivot error bit uh it's just it's just
it's just opening our opportunity
because before you couldn't do really
sports now it's
you can do it just about everything when
did you uh start this company and like
how much money have you already raised
um so i bought out a little print shop
right after graduating college i had a
brian scalibrini design go viral when i
was in school
and so i had enough money to buy this
little print shop out we've since scaled
that
and so we just got mark's investment for
250 000
other than that
everything else was bootstrapped from
the ground up so this is the first time
we're actually raising capital so we
still own most of the company um and we
are cash flow positive we should be
profitable this year there is like a
first movers like we gotta land grab all
these schools pretty quick okay you
gotta stop sam's getting too excited uh
this is a video at a family show we
can't uh we can't cross the line here so
you're saying all the right words yeah i
mean i love you i think i love you i
i bid and my wife is definitely no i'm
i'm i'm totally interested i i think
you've got a lot of charisma you got a
lot of charm you're all the story about
buying the small print shop and then
getting mark cuban be a cold email i
know that it looks like you have light
bank on board they seem like sharks i
don't know much about them but they seem
like
if you got that groupon yeah yeah so
eric
you you you have a very interesting uh
energy about you so i'm definitely
interested in learning more they're
telling us it's time i got one last
question for you which is
these ideas sound fun and i often run
away from fun ideas because you know a
bunch of people go try to do it maybe
the opportunity is not that big because
it's it's fun and sexy um
the the big like youtuber merch back-end
stores like fan joy and some of these
other ones like they pretty much all
suck right none of them got huge what's
the difference here okay sonic's got big
but that's different so you have to
think about like why we're defensible is
because we're we're essentially enabling
our athletes to do the marketing for us
right and so if you have 300 athletes at
the university of indiana all pushing
this store
every year the school's going to be
adding more athletes and then they're
going to be pushing those into our big
funnel so like at the university of
illinois we're sitting on 20 000 illini
emails and now we can step up to
fanatics and start competing with them
because
all of our customer acquisition is
rooted in the kids that are actually
playing does that make sense yes okay so
so spring
so teespring is uh the platform actually
walker is one of my good friends yeah
yeah yeah um and so like a lot of our
stuff there's a small circle of us that
have raising money in the tech space and
apparel we all talk to each other so a
lot of this is calling on a lot of each
other's apis
um and and using a lot of the tech
there's them what you print through them
no we we could print through like we
have our own facility but that doesn't
scale and so um our cto actually came
from a company called printavo shout out
bruce ackerman he got acquired recently
and so we can connect to thousands of
print shops across the country
and so we have the ability to connect
the same way teespring does customing
all the bigger guys right where where do
you live you live in chicago chicago
nice dude
sam's coming over yeah okay
all right you're talking dirty to me
midwestern guy doing all that stuff i'm
i'm very interested
thanksgiving great job talk soon thanks
i like it man that guy had some charisma
i think the business is
more than mildly interesting
yeah yeah he's a good entrepreneur you
could tell right yes like a bunch of the
little like green flags that you would
have to be a good entrepreneur he's got
and um and i think he's got a really
interesting opportunity here because of
the nil change
and uh that's that answers the big why
now question why okay the idea of
printed t-shirt swag is like you know
the oldest solution in the book but
there's a new problem and the new
problem is that all of a sudden athletes
can do this they never could but they
don't know where to start and they're
not going to want to do all this
infrastructure so being the company that
partners with them that's true i think
it's really strong these econ plays can
be freaking tough man walker williams
who the hard part here is upside right
like is this is this a billion dollar
company is this a hundred is this a 10
billion dollar company there's basically
no way this is a 10 billion company
unlikely it's even a billion dollar
company so that's the hard part he's
going to raise on like tech valuation
terms
he's a million cap right now yeah but
what is his revenue
uh i don't know yet he didn't he didn't
say i said seven he said seven million
this year i think he said
i mean
and econ seven million is like not very
much right so but this is none four
million last year he said uh
this is it crosses the threshold uh so
four million last year seven million
this year it crosses the threshold of
being interesting enough to not say no
at least for me
yeah the one thing i would want to be
figuring out here is okay cool you're
going to raise this money at 10 um are
you going to raise money again and is
your do you look does he think about
this mentally like oh i'm a tech founder
i'm going to raise my seed my series a
my series b my series c if so i'd have
to get off the train but if he's
basically like hey
i'm i'm going to fund this and value
this based on the category that i'm in
um which is you know let's say in this
case e-commerce i think our tech enabled
e-commerce i think that there would be a
um
a better conversation there so i think
that's my only concern is how big is the
is the prize i like everything he's
doing but that part's not in his control
yeah well i felt bad for being rude to
him so i'll uh
i'll look at it
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a test from three days ago i
totally missed
hubspot grow better
um all right next tara shroom
jared from terrace room
what's up guys how are we doing what's
up i take it away all right sam and sean
why do people listen to my first million
podcasts
well
it's because they want to make more
money coincidentally tim ferriss says of
all the billionaires i personally know
almost without exception use mushrooms
on a regular basis so if you want to
step up the podcast to my first billion
you might be interested in what we're
building
so terrace room is really
straightforward it's a patent-pending
mushroom grow chamber that is
intelligent and automated and so that
way anyone can grow mushrooms at home
effortlessly
and the problem is is while a lot of
people want to grow mushrooms at home
growing mushrooms is complicated and
it's an eyesore and i've been growing
mushrooms for nearly six years now so
i'm speaking from my own personal
experience
but mushrooms they're becoming a wildly
popular and the space is blowing up with
billions that are spent on mushrooms
annually so
let's transition a bit and let's talk
about product market where we're at so
the past about two months we've spent
about four thousand five hundred dollars
in facebook ads and this has resulted in
nearly sixty five 000 worth of
pre-orders and how our business model is
set up we have subscription revenue
basically growth supplies that we send
every single month when you factor this
in we're looking at over a hundred
thousand dollars when you factor in this
subscription ltv
and this is the team that's making it
all possible so a team is stacked with
deep technical operational and sales
experience we have multiple exits and
ipos under our belt and one who you
might even recognize is an old friend of
yours sam as well as former guests on
this podcast justin mayers so what we're
looking for is uh 500 000 at 3.25 post
money valuation this is going to help
cover all manufacturing costs get it
slated for a q4 launch and ultimately
shipping out in uh q1 of next year
so guys like if you want to be part of
building a product that's helping people
become happier healthier and maybe even
produce a few more billionaires
then we'd love your help to make this
happen thank you
dude that tim ferriss quote ambitious
that's a very rich quote is that real he
said every single one of his billionaire
friends takes mushrooms
a derivative of mushrooms we can say but
uh yes
interesting um well good pitch it looks
good
so explain what it is it's a it's a home
brew kit for growing
shrooms yeah
uh any type of mushroom species so let
me give a little bit of backup so um
there's a couple companies that are kind
of in space right now one is back to the
roots they're doing over a hundred
million dollars right now in revenue per
year okay back to the roads is doing a
hundred million in revenue
yep and then there's mud water there's
four stigmatic basically when you take
of some companies that are in this space
they're doing nearly a quarter billion
dollars from three companies alone
what we're doing right now is we have a
trojan horse this is a beautiful grow
chamber that gets people in the app
ecosystem where we have awesome upsell
opportunities into other verticals
and long-term play is ultimately
therapeutic so when you think of like
the the science the research is
irrefutable legislation's changing it's
2022. big pharma quite frankly they're
they're scared they see the science um
and so we just have a really really
cheap way to basically super cheap
customer acquisition costs get people in
the ecosystem and ultimately down the
line we can almost go down to like
telehealth and a lot of like we're
basically we're not selling atoms
we're ultimately selling like ones and
zeros or bits and bytes
so let me pause you so you said back to
the roots does a hundred million dollars
and you're like that's a comparable but
i go back to the roots and it's like you
know moms and their kids and they're
growing plants at home is what it looks
like not like
you know uh high achievers taking
mushrooms to be happy because they the
money they're cool
yeah
cool mom yeah it seems like a totally
different thing so so let me uh talk a
little bit about distinct uh distinction
uh you can grow any type of mushrooms in
this gourmet medicinal
other varieties as well this is not
limited to the type that you're thinking
of as well as you can even grow
microgreens i mean this is ultimately a
containerized grow environment that
gives you full control over all
environmental settings
so there's a lot that can happen in this
and that's the exciting part is we have
an iot device that's connected in the
home you guys know what's happening with
sodastream traeger grills
doing hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue exact same thing and this is
exactly where we're skating to where the
puck is
and so why do you pitch it like it's the
like psychedelics thing versus hey we're
sodastream for growing like you know
veggies or whatever the hell like
michael
whatever uh there's there's a couple
there's a couple of people in the whole
space right now uh when it comes to uh
you know like hydroponic growth
solutions for like lettuce um and i
think you know the truth is is like what
we're just seeing is uh the green rush
happened a couple years ago uh about a
decade ago in california we're seeing
the exact same thing happen in mushroom
space
and that is where there's going to be
billions and billions of dollars to be
made
so
you can sell i i know nothing about
mushrooms so you can sell that stuff
so here's the thing what we are selling
uh just to be clear what we are selling
is just the grow chamber we're just
selling hardware and we'll say basically
sell some raw and greens you can buy
from the store or what uh what have you
um then we will also sell basically the
grow supplies if you want to do gourmet
varieties fun fact it's not what
something that most people don't know
you can grow you can order any type of
mushroom spore varieties
if you catch my drip because they do not
contain
the psychoactive ingredient in 47 of the
50 u.s states this is a legal loophole
i've been growing them for about six
years all
different types so it's something that
not many people know but it's becoming
very well established are you on shrooms
right now
uh okay this is okay
he didn't answer
[Laughter]
no he's got his wits about him all right
uh okay so you're so you're doing this
and you think that also like you're
growing through paid ads and through
paid ads you're like okay
we're not going to get um
you know blocked by facebook for
basically saying you know grow your own
weed at home like you know that's what
happened they wouldn't allow that but
you're going to basically be able to
show this terrain you know this home you
know a little trade that you're gonna be
able to buy yeah yeah so actually you
know it's funny uh talking just amazing
we're doing a huge pivot away from
actually the whole like anything
psychedelic so it's actually just very
much like generic so um taking it very
much more down a pc route to basically
just grab a much wider audience
wow um
oh okay so so you have some interest
here if you have 40k of interest but
you've you're raising 605 000 is that
right
um
i'm sorry am i reading this around he's
raising 250k 250k at a 3.3 million cap
605 is like in this whole session how
many people have been interested in
funding things he's got
himself and how is this business and
what's going to happen like where what
do you think the exit is
yeah great question um so honestly i've
just been working on this uh for the
past few months uh everything from the
cad modeling design you know
literally everything you've seen uh done
myself so basically we're getting ready
for uh getting some engineering
validation testing and then ultimately
exit strategy is i mean
extremely profitable um
you know acquisitions i mean it's just
like the truth is like we like to make
money that's why you know we're on this
podcast right but
um
there's a lot of different ways
give us the unit economics real quick
you can make them you can make the
device for what and like basically the
cogs plus the shipping is what do you
sell it for yeah perfect so uh what
we're looking right now is 49 and some
change for uh manufacturing when you
factor in cac when you factor in 3pl
basically landed costs you're looking at
about 128 uh msrp is 3.99 and then we
have a 29 a month uh
subscription uh so basically you're
looking at total about seven hundred
dollars uh for the customer ltv based
off of like about a thirty some dollar
cat
okay
all right that's time thank you dude
thanks jared
dude it's crazy man valuations have
changed he's raising a 3.3 million
dollar cap i was thinking about like the
upside here
um
it got thing angel doesn't get far more
attractive in the last three months
yeah these valuations were all extremely
reasonable uh and i think they were also
very early stage so these are like
pre-seed type of investments which is
great because you know that's where a
lot of money can be made um
yeah my wife's definitely out on this
one my wife who has never said a curse
word never drank a drop of alcohol i
don't think she's uh i don't think she's
a believer that uh would would you ever
do shrooms
um i don't know probably not i don't
i don't know i've been trying to tell my
wife to do it this year i'm like hey
before we have kids you should try lsd
or mushrooms or something that'd be
awesome i'm not gonna do it yeah you're
like you should
i'm not gonna do it like like the other
day we were talking about this
relationship book uh like like to make
our relationship better i'm like hey can
you read this for us
yeah
that's how i feel about mushrooms like
hey can you do this for us you know it's
supposed to change change people's lives
and make them feel better and happier
can you do it for both of us um
yeah this is i i would say i'm mildly
interested in this as well i need to
learn more i don't know i his answer of
is this illegal to sell is still
a little no he's saying it's legal he's
saying all we sell is hardware and then
we sell raw ingredients and then 49 of
the 50 whatever states yeah but he used
the phrase
if you catch my drift yeah you never you
never want to use if you catch my drift
and it's a legal loophole uh during your
pitch because that just sort of says uh
you know you're one inch away from this
business collapsing yeah
if you catch my drift yeah that's like
that that's that
that's really interesting to me more
than two winks in your pitch i'm out
like you don't want to be like yeah you
know what i mean
yeah yeah so i i i need to do uh i need
to feel um
i need to learn a little bit more i'm
out but not for that reason i just uh
hardware is hard so if i have the choice
between investing in a hardware company
a software company i'm sort of just
leaning towards software unless there's
a real outlier and then on top of that
um i don't really know this market i
don't know how real the shrooms trend is
if it's just like a lasf new york type
of trend uh for this type of thing i
don't know how big oh wait i i think
it's bigger i think it's i i've read a
couple books about it another like
people that are gonna buy a a four
million a four hundred dollar
uh like you know
nest looking you know clean device
versus just like you know paid diego
across the street for like you know
twenty dollars for some shrooms like i i
of course more people take shrooms but
how many people are going to do this
like yeah that's a good just like sexy
homebrew situation you ever grow
i grew weed in high school in a closet
did you ever do that
i can't say i did
well we used to like go to home depot
and have to like buy the bulbs and stuff
and like put a lock in the closet so
your mom doesn't come into it
these things like
this plus amazon it's like the it's like
the easiest thing ever like to to grow
drugs i love it
[Laughter]
all right we'll go to the next pitch uh
so i think in that case i was out you
were maybe is that right i'm a maybe
okay cool let's do the next one morgan
from deal builder hey guys
what's going on all right so um yeah my
name is morgan i'm the co-founder of
deal builder so shawn and sam have you
guys heard of the baby boomer tsunami
it's a bit of a ridiculous name but it's
the 10 trillion dollars of baby boomer
owned businesses that are going to need
to sell by 2030. the unfortunate reality
is that a majority of them will fail to
sell and the reason why is because the
current marketplace is confusing it's
super expensive and it's really
inefficient how do we know this well
over the past decade my co-founders and
i have sold over 250 businesses and have
really mastered how to sell small
businesses
and
what we've found is that we've developed
a proven system for successfully selling
businesses and we found the solution was
to build a tech platform so we could
rapidly scale and make the process more
efficient and transparent and that's
what we built deal builder an online
marketplace to buy and sell businesses
so what unlike uh typical listing sites
deal builder makes uh the process guided
through end to end which makes deals
close faster and for a fraction of the
cost we make money by taking up to a
three percent platform fee of the
transaction
so our early traction so far we've
closed four and a half million dollars
worth of gmv on the platform uh we have
another eight and a half million under
offer and we launched the platform at
the tail end of 2021
uh and currently that's been a
year-to-date revenue of about 80 000. we
have another 65 million that's listed on
the platform right now and we're
projected to hit a billion of gmv listed
on the platform by the end of 2023.
that represents another
at our current 65 million listed about
600 000 on the platform
and to put in the context that 80 000 of
year-to-date revenue we're doing we did
24 and a half in august and we
anticipate that a similar amount in
september as well so we're just getting
started as those deals are starting to
land
our lead investor is friend of the pod
andrew wilkinson from tiny uh we've
secured 450 000 of canadian dollars in
funding and we're looking to raise
another 250 000 to scale this and take
on this trillion dollar uh problem and
we want to have that chilling there
grindset mindset from you guys on the
cap table as well
what's the conversion of 450 000
canadian dollars to real money
oh it's like you guys are paying like 20
20 or 30 bucks i think yeah yeah
yeah i was just i couldn't figure it out
like what monopoly money to usd is
yeah i know i think that in actuality i
think that's probably like 150 i think
or maybe a little bit more uh us
something like that really okay dude
this is awesome your site is great i
think your branding is really is really
slick and cool it's not you know micro
acquire i think maybe it's because
andrew was just being controversial on
twitter i don't think that he's uh uh
appealing to maybe all the right people
i i think that what you're doing is
incredibly intriguing it's this is very
interesting why haven't you raised from
for more people this seems like a pretty
big opportunity and you only listed
andrew he's great but that's just one
person
yeah so we started out bootstrapped like
we actually just built this for
ourselves for the first little while and
then we kind of just saw we pivoted the
business model at first it was just like
uh all right small businesses that
weren't a good fit for our brokerage you
go and use this and pay like a nominal
fee and then we're like
wait this works with bigger deals and
why not just expand this and that's when
we decided to raise uh so that's we're
kind of seeing that blue ocean right now
and kind of going after it have you
talked to all of our nerdy friends like
well you're talking to me and sean have
you talked to cody have you talked to
nick huber have you talked to all of our
buddies who are all like these
influencers around this stuff
not nick huber i've exchanged the ends
of cody but i haven't finalized
something but i also talked to xavier uh
recently as well who's really in the
space and everybody's like yeah this is
absolutely needed because well like
amongst our little like circle jerk
group of friends who talk about buying
boring businesses i think you you'd have
a nice little influencer uh at least not
like not a game changing but maybe a
little game changing but anyway
uh i would probably invest a little bit
i would like to learn more and do some
due diligence but this is really really
cool
how much how big is buy-based sell
yeah so biz buy sell whatever way you
want to do it is so it's owned by
co-star and co-star owns loopnet and
they're a public company i think they
did 2.1 billion of revenue but they're
just listing they don't take any
transactional fees so our difference
with biz by sell is that they i think
businesses for sale is another
competitor they do a hundred and they
had 160 000 listings in 2019 but they
don't they probably do you know 5
million revenue because they don't take
any piece of the transaction so the
their value capture is so low to what
they actually could be delivering on but
they're just a listing site so they only
just send buyer leads they don't
actually help guide through the
acquisition sean why'd you ask about
that versus um like fe international
because uh it seems like that's the
closest comp right business myself for
the types of businesses you're selling
like when i go to your site i see like
chocolate shop i.t services company so
like micro requires trying to do sas
yeah we don't touch it specifically and
um fe international is doing you know
larger deals that are using basically
like a kind of like a private banker um
whereas it looks like this is kind of
like how the smbs are going to trade
hands is what you're trying to do is
that accurate yeah an fe international
could be a client of ours so we have a
brokerage like a white label side so our
brokerage now runs all of our deals
through deal builder and pays a small
percentage of every completed deal and
we do their whole back office for them
so they don't have so with brokers your
cash flows like this because it's in
between each commission so now they're
only paying when deals actually come
through so brokers have just kind of
like flooded to it and asked to be on
the platform which is really cool i
think more than anything i'm invest i'm
i'm interested in the i mean i think
your brand is cool you seem nice and
great and competent i think that i'm
interested in the macro trend yeah
you're handsome like a baby dolph
lundgren
um
yeah like a little ivan drago i think
that um
i think that uh this macro trend is
really cool
and i would like to take a part of that
so how do you get the crank going so how
are you going to get a bunch of buyers
and sellers onto this platform like what
do what does that take uh i'm sure it's
a bunch of brute force at the beginning
but
what you're doing to make that happen
yeah so uh the sell side's harder than
the buy side buyers are everywhere like
everyone thinks buyers are the problem
but it's super easy to find them and
it's free to sign up so really low
friction um feel free to sign up
watchers and so on the seller side we've
really grown by referrals so accountants
other brokers so brokers refer deals to
the platform as well and then just
awareness like people don't know that
these solutions exist so it's actually
really nice from a marketing perspective
you just say hey you can sell your
business on our platform they're like
great i had no idea i thought my
business wasn't worth anything so it's
really just getting awareness and
getting into the right centers of
influence and i think like you're
talking about with some of those
influencers i think could make a really
big difference and your revenue this
year is going to be a couple hundred
thousand is that right yeah likely it's
a little bit hard to predict when when
the timing of deals will close but in
our pipeline of 600 000 right now i know
a couple hundred thousand of that will
close for sure and just in the quality
of the businesses um and we've already
done 80 80 to
yeah 80 000 this year already have you
paid the bills on your team it looks
like on your website it looks like you
got a bunch of people listed uh yeah
well the three the co-founders i'm the
active operating co-founder the other
two co-founders uh are really kind of
advisor and and uh investor roles so
they were and help out with some of the
with the actual um
kind of like breaking down the brokerage
process and then so there's two
developers myself and a marketing person
one of them is on matt leave right now
but uh yeah so it's like there's like
four of us right now that are on payroll
sick well thank you this is awesome i'm
i'd like to learn more
yeah same all right thanks morgan good
job um sean the thing he said at the end
little little funky little funky what
the team not being the team yeah the
team not being the team that's it that
that
freaks me out a little bit because in a
couple years when things start working
out well if i'm that kid i'm gonna say
well what the hell man you're not even
working here why do you deserve this
equity and uh you know like there's
gonna be some anger and we don't know
that they have equity uh we don't know
how much they're listed as a co-founder
yeah but that might just be like it
seems like so if you go to their website
there's this like stock photos of like
you know happy people holding you know
coffees and like clipboards and like um
you know it seems like maybe he just
buffed up the team to be like look our
team has tons of experience uh yeah no
big deal
so if it's a
website marketing thing okay that's fine
uh but if it's
actually on the cap table or it's in the
deck and then you're in the deck and
here's our awesome team with tons of
experience oh i'm the only one who
actively works on this that's when i'm
like okay hold on how many other things
in this deck do i need to question so i
think that's a little bit of a you know
yeah that's all i'm saying i don't think
it's the red flag i'm just saying i
would want to dig in just a little bit
more on that
right
but that guy just raised 250 thousand
dollars it said it said he was raising
250 and he had 250 of interest so good
for him
i'm a million dollars of total interest
for this session so um
when you talk about
moving moving weight when you talk about
bringing size when you talk about
really
hitting
all right let's go to the last pitch
it is tim from field complete all right
tim
hey guys
um
field complete is a free app for your
local plumber or electrician to run
their business
they live in our app and we become their
bank over time we found a very unique
wedge into this market
as you know rentership in the us is on
the rise over 35 percent of all homes
are rented and it's growing it all
started back in 08 when uh all the
foreclosed homes or most of them were
bought out by wall street and rented
pair that would like the short-term
rental airbnb craze and millennials not
being able to or wanting to own heck now
even like vcs
are buying real estate portfolios right
through adam newman uh so all these
homes need to be professionally
maintained by property managers and
property managers use contractors and
subcontractors uh to maintain them and
so the problem is that traditionally
contractors would either focus on the
residential sector with homeowners or
the commercial jobs and with property
managers entering the single family uh
rental scene uh as a contractor you're
basically either forced to bootstrap
your operation uh seven different apps
to run your business or your resort to
pen and paper which is basically 80 of
contractors today um and actually my
co-founder experienced this problem
firsthand when he transitioned his
construction company he tried the seven
seven different app route ended up
building his own and only after the subs
and the property manager started asking
like hey what software are you using we
realize how huge this problem is so in a
nutshell field complete is a free
software for your local home service
contractor to run their business and
over time we essentially become their
point of sale their bank their credit
card think of it like a shopify for the
home service contractor
as far as traction goes we raised a
small precede to rebuild the app uh we
launched at the beginning of this year
have over 200 contractors on the
platform serviced over 19 000 homes over
5 million in gmv this year on track to
do 10 million we're only currently
monetizing uh the actual revenue on the
merchant services so anytime a credit
card is swiped uh and there we're on try
to do a little over 100k this year we're
raising a 2.5 million seed to integrate
banking into the solution add job
sharing which basically
gives us more users pilot with a
property manager and integration
and hire some support reps um and uh
this note we know this model works well
because ever since we've removed the
sauce fees we've been getting about
three to four
companies signing up organically every
day
so i'll open it up for questions
tim you and i have interacted a bunch
online haven't we
yes we did i know you're uh i know your
face um but we've never hung out have we
not yet
here oh let's
what's going on nice to meet you this is
a cool congratulations when was the
first raise that you did
yeah so the first race uh was um a year
and a half ago about almost two years
tim what why no deck
um we went with the no deck that's
attached to the the the thing a
distraction
okay
uh all right sounds good are you running
out of money now
uh no we we have enough room we have
more than like seven months of runway
and this round is coming together so we
have a lead for this round uh it's we're
basically most likely going to close it
in the next month or two here um so we
have a lead all the investors from
pre-seed basically exercise their
paratha into the round uh and we have
some new investors coming in and how
much is how many people will work there
and what's your spend each month roughly
yeah so uh total team size is 18 right
now um we uh burn about 60 to 70k a
month
today in netburn
yeah
and you're raising how much
uh we're doing we're raising 2.5 um
we can potentially oversubscribe it but
we think that's enough money for us to
get to like the next stage
and last question on that what's the
next stage
yeah so next stage is uh basically this
money will get us to either default
alive or raise a bigger growth round um
like
we're on track so right now uh the the
the companies are signing up organically
through subcontracting and so the user
base is growing uh on its own we
literally only have two support reps on
the team right now uh and that's
like customer acquisition in this space
is tough because it's smb and it's
fragmented right um and so
we found this wedge where through
property managers they they work with
multi-trade contractors and they sub
jobs to each other on our platform and
that and we get more and more users this
way signing up um on their own
and so therefore our cac is not as high
like we don't spend money on cac
basically all the users that we
currently have on the platform are
organic
uh so say that again so how many users
do you currently have on the platform
and
uh
over what period of time were they
acquired
yeah so for this year we've had about
500 contractors sign up um all of those
um basically
200 are
active um and then this like some
contractors are daily active weekly
active monthly we're tracking all of
that uh the daily active are the ones
that live inside our software uh the
weekly and monthly are the ones that
would basically you use the app um like
to receive work and perform work from
the contractor so they're just using it
to basically receive a job and do it uh
with the new feature that i was talking
about the job sharing that we're gonna
release they're gonna get a full field
complete account as well and they'll be
able to use it for all the third party
work and right now you're keeping one
percent
of the money that goes through you guys
yeah so merchant services were out like
when we were raising our precedent we're
thinking it's gonna be up to one percent
we're doing like
and the deca says 1.07 the actual is
1.26 um
right now but with a goal of 10
yeah so um
yes the answer is yes and the way we get
there is um we're going to release the
in like q1 the banking solution that's
going to average out to about two
percent there's other other fintech
offerings we can layer on top basically
like settling invoices earlier kind of
the way deal does it and other fintech
offerings there and then from there we
want to pilot with a property manager
integrate with them and give them our
book of contractors to dispatch work to
and they will give their book of
contractors back to us right
and so let me ask you a question
uh when you internally forget about the
pitch when you look at the health of
your business
what is the
number one kpi so what is the the main
kpi for you
yeah so we're measuring gmv across the
board because that's what we can
monetize we can add uh layers of
monetization in terms of like
marketplace fees so the gm gmv is your
number one metric and gmv matters
because that's what flows through your
app directly yes
so you're saying gmv matters because i
take one percent of gmv
yes today yes 1.26
um then and we without increasing the
user base we can layer more offerings on
top of that and increase the revenue as
it scales
what is the math come out there so you
basically the last year you've done like
70k of revenue something like that
5.7 million of gmv and then you multiply
that by 1.26 is that right
yeah so uh for for this year right uh
this past year we did we had about 5.7
gmv to date um we're at
about 42 000 in revenue already uh we
will be at the end of the year basically
uh at 100
over 100k
so i personally i like the concept of
what you're doing which is basically the
you know the sort of workflow slash um
you know how to run your business if
you're a
blue collar contractor here um i really
like that concept
uh but what i don't like about this
pitch is i'm just confused as to like
how big your business is i feel like you
threw a bunch of numbers you're like oh
we service 19 000 homes 5.7 million in
gmv these sound really big but what's
the reality the reality is you have 200
active users and you made 40 000 in
revenue this year right that's the
reality of the situation and i feel like
that was so buried in this that i'm like
for me personally that's too much work
to get to
an understanding of your business which
tells me that the under that the
business if the business itself was
super compelling you would have just led
with
the more clear easy to understand
metrics that are like
not like we serve 19 000 homes which is
a total of 43 000 people because four
people live in the home it's like oh
dude like i don't know well i don't know
what these numbers are but they're
irrelevant to
what your actual business is is your
growth keeping you up at night right now
what's keeping you up at uh keeping you
up at night where you think like
things are going well which everyone at
all stages now business thing so when
i'm not saying it for you but just like
you're i'm not saying you have this only
everyone has it so what what are you
saying that about
yeah so growth has actually been very
good because we're getting organic users
we're not paying anything for these
users the pi is growing on its own how
can you say that you have 200 active
users how could you say growth is very
good like i don't know yeah so the the
reason why it's good is because we spend
basically no money acquiring them right
so we're getting through those companies
that's just saying i have you know i
have i have so many friends i have three
friends but i don't go out so it's no
problem you know it's like well my
muscles are really good for not working
out yeah exactly i can do two reps i
never work out it's like well the point
was to have really strong muscles the
point for you is to have a lot of
customers
you maybe you should be spending to get
more customers right
yeah so where we're at now is like um
we're onboarding customers like i said
that that are coming in and then as far
in terms of revenue it trickles in a bit
later when it's a fintech solution right
right so that that's
that might be a concern for an investor
but our investors online with us
like if we were to turn on sauce fees
today right we'd make up like i around
four to five hundred thousand dollars
in arr but we're
purposefully keeping them low so when
subcontract there's no barrier to entry
and then we monetize the financial layer
and so
because of that it's basically we're
prioritizing growth over immediate
revenue right at this moment um and so
that's our strategy again and our
investors outlined with it i would argue
so you're basically saying we're not
charging because we don't want to have a
barrier to entry any business that
doesn't charge is going to get that
benefit but then you should see awesome
growth right uh and so that's that's
that would be the counter argument the
counter argument would be okay you've
you've sacrificed 400 500 000 in revenue
you're like you're saying
and what have you gotten in return is
some you know 200 active 500 total
registered users
if you had just
just charged and actually had 400 000 in
revenue you could go if you spent that
money on advertising you could probably
have
you know 10 times more users so
uh i don't know i guess for me uh those
parts don't add up personally because
i uh and i'm saying this too just
because you know on the show there's a
lot of people listening so they want to
hear the full thought process which is
um i think in general you want to have a
capital efficient business it seems like
you might have spent
uh you've raised 1.6 million to date is
that correct
yeah so in this round already and yeah
are like okay in the life of the company
how much money has been like burned
total
yeah total burn is uh like we've burned
about 1.8 to date right so what i would
say is okay if if i knew nothing else
about your business i would say here's a
business that has burned 1.8 million
dollars to achieve 200 customers and 50
000 of revenue this year that's the
harsh truth about like the business now
that doesn't mean you don't invest there
might be tons of other reasons why that
that burn was on infrastructure building
product building a brand whatever there
are other reasons but like just sort of
objectively speaking that would be my
main issue and i give you that feedback
because
maybe you can look at your model
slightly if others share that point of
view maybe they don't maybe they do but
if others shared that point of view then
you could say all right
um the feedback from the investor market
is that i need to either have an
impressive user number or an impressive
revenue number um you know and and maybe
i should double down on one of those
areas and do things slightly differently
the stocks guys are saying we gotta end
this this particular presentation tim we
appreciate you a lot um
coming on this is awesome thank you yes
sam sean thanks thanks thanks sorry if i
was too harsh buddy dude um
i hate doing this because i agree with
everything you say i hate i don't want
to rip on someone but here's the here's
the thing
i think the business
could be great i think
maybe there's a chance that he just kind
of missed the pitch a little bit
but yeah that could totally be the case
and or are we misunderstood right
because without a deck you're trying to
follow it while you're trying to read
the chat while you're trying to look for
the company's metrics and you go to
their website so it's very easy to miss
things during that process so that might
be on us
um and the other part of it is um some
information the the the lead was buried
when the lead is buried i get i get us
a spidey thing goes off where i'm like
i'm nervous what am i nervous about here
now that doesn't mean that it's always
the case or that he meant to do that but
he could have just been nervous or
something because there are a lot of
people watching but there some the pitch
the pitch was missed
and i feel like you know on one hand i'm
like you what you said was just like
dude i hate kind of saying
uh you know something not positive to an
entrepreneur because i know how hard it
is to be an entrepreneur and be a fan i
don't mind doing it when it's just me
and them
yeah especially in this this format uh
but you know if you sign up to do this
if we us signing up to do this publicly
and a founder standing up to this
publicly that's the point right the
point of this is it's
you're putting yourself out there
there's a risk and reward with that um i
think you have to know that going in but
but i think that you know the best thing
that can happen is if you
um i don't know if i'm right but if i
was
it would be short it would be a little
pain today for a lot more you know
benefit down the road right hard today
easy later if we just keep it easy now
and say oh this looks really interesting
would love to chat more and just bounce
i mean you never know what what why we
might not want it
you you you nailed it which was
answered the question why it's it was
1.5 million or eight 1.8 million for 200
customers
and 80 000 or 160 000 whatever it was in
revenue um there is a good answer or
there could be a good answer to that
which is like dude we're building
software just it takes forever but once
these guys get on us they like are
hooked forever and they tell their
friends and like here's what here's how
we grow uh and here's how the math looks
like i just think that he kind of didn't
present that wonderfully even if the
truth is good right right right um okay
so i don't know are we doing anything
else here no that's it last pitch
uh thank you to everybody who showed up
that was that was great i think there
was at least two companies in there that
i know i would i'm going to follow up
with which ones
um campus inc i thought was really
interesting yeah and the pillpack one uh
was really good too i think those are my
my top two what about for you
i think i like campus inc and i like the
business what was the uh oh deal builder
deal builder also is a good one and all
the valuations are fantastic deal
builders at four million
deal builders interesting well this last
one was at 21 million that's why i asked
him when he last raised was he raised 18
or 24 months ago when uh
when things were hot and uh
yeah yeah and if your valuation is 21
million the bar is higher on what you
need to deliver right the pillpack guy's
like ah we got two thousand you know he
said like we've made 1500 in revenue or
something like that but he launched two
months ago and um he's raising at like a
three or four million dollar cap right
so yeah like that they don't push as
hard on that
like when i think about what i'm doing
with my personal money right now i'm
like man like i think some of these tech
stocks like or just just the total index
is just a little like under price at the
moment and i think like there's gonna be
some upside and then i look at like a 20
million dollar company and i'm like okay
this is still super high risky and it
needs to have a fairly good outcome to
make the risk worth it for me whereas a
four million dollar deal
with just one guy working on it you know
it's like you know yeah that could
actually survive a little bit maybe
higher likelihood it could survive in it
and it the return could be great so
down in a way that's where i am this is
uh i love that the chat here these
people are such like there's so many
funny people and like interesting smart
people yeah the chat makes it a lot of
fun uh like henry just now just goes
he's like this
uh this this uh this pitch was wld whole
lot of dogs
dude
i love this man these guys are great so
i uh i almost kind of want to have i can
do a pod every once in a while we have a
live chat this is actually quite good
yeah maybe we should uh and thanks for
coming out if people like this dong sing
this is the second time we've done this
live pitch if it's cool we'll do it
again dude these guys stocks
like i'm biased here but i'm impressed
every time i i go on their platform it
is cool isn't it
yeah it's pretty sweet so that's not
like such a pitch sorry but it's really
cool
we're at 1.3 million of total interest
was expressed so they really did help
these companies raise money um pretty
dope 500 people were here kind of
hanging out
and uh all right that's it we're out of
here
[Music]
you